[Musik]
hey was geht ab und jetzt willkommen
beim ein video was geht
ich hab grad in die kamera guckt und ich
finde meine lippen heutiger extrem roth
und schließlich warum auf jeden fall
jetzt weiß die letzten drei tage kam ist
wieder kein video liegt daran
ich wollte heute eigentlich schön und 14
uhr dieses video raushauen hat nicht
geklappt hat ein bisschen verschlafen so
ich will jetzt auch keine ausreden
lassen finden sei es uns egal auf jeden
fall habe ich gesehen mein letztes video
ist im wortlaut nachrichten gingen kam
wirklich echt gut anders hat schon über
400.000 news und da hast du dir aleks
wenn ihr das so feiert da muss noch was
kommen ich habe mich hingesetzt und
überlegt was kannst du machen und bin
auch die geniale idee gekommen mir zum
titel gelesen es geht heute um die
witzigsten water award nachrichten an
ein ex freund oder eine ex-freundin sind
echt ein paar sachen dabei ich will gar
nicht länger für noch ein paar platz
nach oben da 15.000 neigt wie immer ihr
seid es geworden selbst ins tor schoss
das team die immer am anfang okay können
meinen körper schreiben welche mir am
ende am witzigsten findet also ich finde
da kann man echt lassen also hätte mal
eins geht an einen gewissen arschloch
ich wusste gar nicht dass es den
vornamen heute schon so gibt es also
abschluss bekommen folgende nachricht
mega flop mit folgenden geschickt hessen
bleibt zurück kommt ein wie geht's dir
sehr gut und die acht mann du wirst nie
wieder jemanden wie mich finden
darüber legt ganz kurz was er schreiben
wollen oder sie
ich denk mal nr das bisher auch der sinn
der sache auf jeden fall sehr gut
gekannt hat aber damit hast du person
ich sage jetzt einfach mal personal
bestimmt noch mehr verletzt
nur der nächste schritt betrifft
eigentlich gar nicht so direkt die
ex-freundin ex freund sondern eher
indirekt und zwar auf platz 1
gespeichert ich glaube ich muss dir was
erzählen was seht her was hast du getan
naja ich war doch letztens mal auf einer
party und naja zu reden bevor du mir
sagt musst du auch wissen dass ich mit
meiner besten freundinnen geschlafen
habe
spinnst du ich wollte dir nur sagen dass
ich seine kleine schwester mit einem
älteren rummachen haben du [ __ ] melde
ich nie wieder bei mir also nicht mehr
schwarz sondern ex freund dann mal da
kann man auch auf jeden fall mal
klatschen also so kann es auch enden
also wenn ihre freundinnen freuen habt
macht es doch einfach mal so und
schreibt auch so naja ich war letztens
auf einer party und wenn ihr glück habt
oder wenn ich halt da ist er mir
wirklich 100 prozent vielleicht entsteht
ihren aufgrund stadt dijon ist denke ich
gering aber es könnte sein
als nächstes haben babys und zwar wird
baby geschick ich vermisse dich komm
bitte zurück baby antwortet wo bist du
andere person schleift zuhause warum
beschreibt geh mal ans fenster okay bin
am fenster und dann schreibt baby
einfach springmesser baby was denn los
mit dir du bist doch mal in berlin also
da muss ich wirklich sagen das ist
extrem hart und da muss man die andere
person schon echt hassen warum auch
immer aber so was kann man doch nicht
schreiben konnte wartet der person
zusammen und schreibt sie dann zu gast
war
ich stell dir vor deine ex freundin war
aixtron keine ahnung es wirklich so
verletzt dass er wirklich runter springt
das ist ja heutzutage gar nicht mehr so
unrealistisch ich mein wenn man ab und
zu mal sieht wer sich westlichen um
bringt ihnen das ganze cybermobbing oder
sonst war ich weiß gar nicht warum ich
auf diese schiene ab dürfte eigentlich
sollte das video heute witzig werden
aber da muss man ganz einfach mal sagen
hey vielleicht hätte man das auch ein
bisschen anders formulieren können so
der nächste schritt jeder next einen
gewissen ex und erst reif oder sie mir
erst etwas wünsche dir zu weihnachten
das verstehe ich jetzt eigentlich nicht
weil wenn das denn extra etwas geht
jetzt gleich daraus hervor
der hat nämlich kein interesse mehr aber
fragt was sie sich zu weihnachten
wünscht da muss dann in gewisser weise
noch interesse da sein sonst würde er
nicht fragen
ok ich weiß nicht wie schreibt auf jeden
fall ein einhorn
er schreibt bleibt bitte realistisch
dann schreibt sie mein größter wunsch
ist natürlich dass du zu mir
zurückkommen und darauf sagt er
welche farbe soll das einhorn fragen
dein ernst das finde ich schon so
traurig das tut mir sogar selber will
schaufenster ein bisschen witzig ist so
aber hey da für dich wirklich immer
richtig mit welche farbe soll das ein
haben das eine ist ein realistischer als
das ärztliche zurückkommen das muss
schon was heißen
du hast du denn dennis den denn es wird
geschickt und ein ernst das ist deine
neue dennis schreibt fragezeichen
sie schreibt du hast echt nen schlechten
geschmack denn es bleibt deshalb war ich
auch mit ihr zusammen da hat er denn es
aber richtig
ein richtiger dennis k dennis kennt man
ja immer so als richtigen draufgänger
dennis kevin ich will jetzt gar keine
vorurteile hier treffen
aber du bist du ein ganz schönes
schlitzohr denn ok man muss auch ganz
ehrlich sagen wenn sie so ankommt dein
ernst das ist eine neue da war das echt
richtig guter konter
das könnte ich mir merken solltet ihr
euch alle merken nicht schlecht so unten
schuss kommen wir noch zu einem webchat
wenn die heutige jugend sich mit elf
jahren schon verliebt ich wusste gar
nicht mit elf was liebe ist aber dann
sieht das folgendermaßen aus das hat
mich geschickt bekommen und zwar ich
hasse dich aber gleichzeitig wie wichtig
obwohl du so eine [ __ ] bis und ich
vermisse unsere zeit aber du bist die
größte mit baby du bist toll und mega
scheiße soll ich dich lieben oder hassen
fragezeichen ausruf seien weiterhin auf
sein zeichen ausgezeichnet ach ich weiß
nicht was ich dazu sagen soll keine
ahnung ich würde sagen dass man jetzt
erstmal die witzigsten die ich so
gefunden habt euch überlassen nach oben
da weiß man doch nicht gibt sie nicht so
website checks folge können immer
schreiben auf was ich mich da beziehen
dolphins netze wir sehen uns morgen
wieder wort kommt eine kasse box
automaten challenge ihrer kirmes oder
sein